bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat alors que la france et
de nombreux autres pays d'europe
connaissent des pics de pollution je
vous propose cet après-midi de revoir ou
de découvrir les auditions menées par la
commission denquête ici au sénat sur
l'impact économique et financier de la
pollution de l'air pour rappel cette
commission a été créée le 11 février
dernier
son but est bien dressés un peu un
constat de des conséquences de la
pollution de l'air sur l'économie
française et la santé des français et
proposer des propositions concrètes pour
lutter contre ce fléau
quand on sait que 40 à 50 mille décès
sont liés directement ou indirectement à
cette pollution de l'air
cet après midi je vous propose de revoir
les auditions de deux représentants du
commissariat général au développement
durable celle de xavier bonnet et celle
de doris nicklaus tout de suite
direction votre audition
donc notre dernière audition de la
matinée et celles de monsieur xavier
bonnet chef du service de l'économie de
l'évaluation et de l'intégration du
développement durable de madame doris
nicklausse chef du bureau déchets
ressources et matières au sein de ce
service au commissariat général 2 au
développement durable et de monsieur
valéry mots rares pardon le commissariat
général au développement durable a été
créée en 2009 au sein du ministère de
l'écologie il a pour mission notamment
de promouvoir le développement durable
dans les politiques publiques et les
comportements des acteurs privés je
rappelle que cette audition est ouverte
au public et à la presse qu'elle fait
l'objet d'une captation politique
audiovisuelle qui sera diffusé sur le
site du sénat
je vais maintenant conformant la
procédure applicable commission enquête
vous demander monsieur et madame de
prêter serment je rappelle pour la forme
d'un faux témoignage devant une autre
commission serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 14 et 15
du code pénal que vous pourrez visiter
dans l'après midi
monsieur xavier bonnet prêté serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
lever la main droite dit je te jure
madame doris miklos a prêté serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levé la main droite et dit je le jure
chine jure et monsieur valéry morard
prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité levé la main droite
et dit je le jure
quelques rires madame et messieurs à la
suite du de votre copain de introductif
je passerai la parole à madame leila
aichi qui est notre rapporteur de cette
commission denquête qui vous posera
évidemment un centre de questions à la
suite de quoi avec notre collègue qui
s'est absenté quelques minutes
éventuellement d'autres gueule et qui
pourrait encore nous rejoindre nous
aurons un échange qui devrait en tous
les cas pouvoir se finir pour 13h vous
avez la parole merci merci monsieur le
sénateur madame la sénatrice
donc je veux commencer par vous exposer
un petit peu les activités du
commissariat général au développement
durable qui concerne
le sujet de la pollution de l'air est
donc dans un deuxième temps nous serons
évidemment tout à fait
donc là répondre à vos questions le
comme vous le disiez le commissariat
général a été créée en 2009 au sein du
grand ministère qui s'était constitué à
l'époque réunissant l'énergie les
transports les l'eau la biodiversité les
la prévention des risques et à l'époque
il y avait aussi le logement qui était
dans le périmètre
donc il y avait besoin à l'époque
d'aller d'avoir au delà des directions
générales qui s'occupe de chacun de ces
aspects secteur secteur sectorielle il y
avait besoin d'avoir un commissariat qui
met de la transversalité danser au
travers de ces sujets sur trois piliers
un pilier d'observation et statistiques
et donc j'ai mon collègue valérie molle
mort harkis et sous-directeurs dans ce
service de l'observation et de la
statistique
à côté de moi hein c'est un service
plutôt une direction de la recherche et
innovation qui consiste dans le travail
et d'orienter la recherche en matière de
enfin d'environnement de donc en
particulier sur le sujet de la pollution
de l'air et puis ce service dont je
m'occupe qui est le service en quelque
sorte d études et de l'animation des
acteurs donc on essaye de faire des
études en particulier économiques sur
les sujets du ministère alors pour
préciser un petit peu les productions
que le commissariat général a eu
l'occasion de faire ces derniers temps
en matière de pollution de l'air
d'abord sur l'aspect statistique et
observations le document le plus récent
est le bilan annuel de la qualité de
l'air en france qui est sortie en
octobre l'année dernière et qui passe en
revue toutes les pollutions de l'air
donc on pourra revenir dans le détail en
répondant à vos questions les sources de
données qui sont utilisés sont
évidemment très multiples et le service
de l'observation et des statistiques a
justement pour vocation de synthétiser
tout la production de données qui peut
se faire au sein du ministère et parfois
au delà
s'agissant de la recherche d'innovation
le grand domaine de recherche de grands
programmes de recherche qui est co
piloté par la direction de la recherche
innovation c'est le programme primequal
c signifie programme de recherche inter
organismes pour une meilleure qualité de
l'air donc c'est un programme de
recherche qui est mise en oeuvre au sein
du ministère avec l'ademe a donc l'
agence de l'environnement et de la
maîtrise de l'énergie
donc il s'agit d'orienter un certain
nombre d'études
qu'elle soit sur la mesure des
pollutions qu'elle soit sur les impacts
sanitaires et qui touche également
parfois au côté études économiques
également voir sociologique et pour
finir donc je je mentionnerai les
activités récent du service de
l'économie dont je m'occupe et avec ma
collègue doris miklos
nous avons un certain nombre de
productions récentes sur les impacts
économiques monétaires monétariser de
ces pollutions avec je mentionnerai en
particulier alors j'ai un certain nombre
de documents ici que je vous laisserai
en partant bien entendu et puis une
liste de publications évidemment qu'ils
sont tout public sur internet accessible
mais j'en ai apporté quelques
exemplaires papier donc je voulais
mentionner de quatre pages qui font bien
là la synthèse des études économiques on
a pu faire dans mon service publiés fin
2013 l'une sur les coups mesurés par
les affections respiratoires et les
coûts pour la sécurité sociale
donc je crois que vous avez largement
parlé juste avant puisque c'est un
travail qu'on a dont le dont l'auteur a
évidemment travailler avec avec des
personnes extérieures au commissariat
général donc qui mesurent donc ce coup
c'est à peu près entre grossièrement 1
milliard à 2 milliards par an
selon les le périmètre des valeurs qu'on
utilise pour chacune des affections
respiratoires étudier et puis donc une
autre publication qui est beaucoup plus
avec un périmètre beaucoup plus générale
qui touche pas uniquement les affections
respiratoires mais qui touche l'impact
sur la mortalité la morbidité et qu'ils
chiffrent le coût pour la société d de
la pollution de l'air à dans une
fourchette de 20 à 30 milliards par an
donc ça c'est ce sont les deux études
alors ces deux études évidemment sont
complétées par des études et documents
dont une publication beaucoup plus
épaisses qui affine la présentation de
ces de ses calculs voilà donc je voulais
brossé très vite déjà le panorama de des
travaux qui sont effectués au
commissariat
nous pouvons rentrer dans davantage de
détails à votre votre guise
en répondant à vos questions et en se
focalisant si vous voulez je vous aviez
envoyé un certain nombre de questions
donc il ya pas mal de questions qui
portent sur la statistique est par
ailleurs des questions qui portaient
plutôt sur les coûts économiques donc à
votre votre disposition merci pour tous
les cas cette présentation synthétique
tellement l'habitude madame là à porter
si vous voulez bien merci monsieur le
président merci pour votre de votre
exposé
j'aurai deux questions l'une en lien
avec la pollution de l'eau est également
sur la biodiversité est ce qu'on peut
faire un lien entre la pollution de
l'air et la pollution de l'eau et est ce
que vous avez également pu faire une
estimation à la hausse et à la baisse
sur la perte de la biodiversité de la
biodiversité qui seraient directement
liées ou indirectement liés à la
pollution de l'air pour les deux
premières questions
avant de je passerai la parole à valérie
mots rares mais le lien entre pollution
de l'air et pollution de l'eau existe
évidemment ne serait ce que parce que
d'un point de vue scientifique il ya
bien il ya bien une porosité et en
particulier avec le ruissellement va on
va avoir des pollutions de l'air qui
vont se retrouver dans les eaux en
matière de chiffrage c'est évidemment
très compliqué je me tourne vers mon
collègue pour savoir si éventuellement
il ad des compléments sur ces aspects là
ensuite tout de même en matière de
pollution de l'eau il ya aussi tout un
travail de monétarisation des pollutions
de l'eau qui qui
un mobilisés au cgdd avec un effort
effectivement et des publications
d'ailleurs avec un effort de de donner
de la valeur ou à ces externalités ses
effets que des actions privées déclenché
sur l'ensemble de la société
mais ce sont des les pollutions de l'eau
en général qui ont été regardées et donc
elles ne sont pas nécessairement liés
fait même en général elles ne sont pas
directement liées aux pollutions de
l'air
donc elles vont plutôt être lié à des
dépressions
environnementale venant d'activité soit
agricole soit soit industriel avec
les nitrates ou d'autres d'autres
d'autres donc pas directement liées aux
pollutions de l'air le lien entre
pollution de l'air et les pollutions de
l'eau oui merci donc le lien tout
d'abord il n'ya pas une vision
quantifier synthétique à l'échelon de la
surface française métropolitaine de
quantifier question polluants par
polluants cependant et déjà il ya un
programme de surveillance européen
on vous donnera le lien de ce programme
qui s'intitule emep qui vise ajustements
à quantifier cette pollution
atmosphérique transfrontière à longue
distance
ça n'est pas négligeable pour donner
justin une illustration
lorsqu'on va faire des bilans azotés
on a de l'ordre de 30 kg d'azoté
qui se dépose naturellement sur sur le
sol et donc c'est intégré et bien
évidemment lorsqu'on va parler de
pollution des eaux par les nitrates une
partie du bilan et de l'excès éventuel
d'azoté tient en partie à ces apports
qui aurait peut-être pas été intégrés
dans la quantification de la
fertilisation par exemple ça c'était
pour illustrer de manière très très
agricole l'ineris et sans doute
l'institut qui possède la meilleure
vision il a mené quelques études dont
une conque on veut citer qui porte sur
le bassin de la seine et qui mettaient
en évidence des situations assez
importante de dépôts atmosphériques de
deux types de polluants les achats p les
hydrocarbures aromatiques polycycliques
et les polychlorobiphényles les pcb est
où là les apports atmosphériques étaient
dominants par rapport aux autres
situations de contamination sur sur les
surfaces voilà donc c'est ça illustre
que sur quelques points particuliers
quelques polluants il peut y avoir un
effet assez déterminant sur leur le
reste des autres polluants
on va dire macro polluants pesticides de
ce type là
les effets tels qu'on peut les
quantifier sont négligeables par rapport
aux autres sources
pour répondre à la deuxième question
biodiversité
là on n'a pas de voix là ya un grand
travail bon vous savez qu'en ce moment
il ya la loi sur la reconquête de la
nature des paysages qui est qui qui est
en cours de discussion elle vise
notamment à tall est une agence
française pour la biodiversité et elle
va rassembler les différents moyens de
connaissance et d'observation pour mieux
connaître la biodiversité terrestre et
aquatique marine actuellement il ya un
observatoire national de la biodiversité
qui a déterminé un certain nombre de
programmes d'acquisition de données pour
construire des indicateurs pour
l'instant on n'a pas cette ce type de
relation entre dépollution venant de
l'air et
il est à la biodiversité par contre il
commence à y avoir des relations entre
l'état des ressources aquatiques et pas
simplement la biodiversité aquatique
mais aussi la biodiversité terrestre
donc là il ya de l'acquisition dans le
domaine aérien
les seuls les choses qui peuvent être
faites sont liées au programme de
surveillance en lui-même puisqu'il
prévoit notamment puisqu'il ya une
répartition du réseau des stations dites
fonds rural et ce qui permet d'évaluer
d'évaluer d'éventuelles effet il ya une
certaine période on en parle beaucoup
moins maintenant parler d'acidification
donc des missions acides dans l'air et
donc là il y avait un programme de
surveillance spécifique forestier qui
visait à mettre en relation les
émissions dans l'air celte pouvait
retomber sur le sol vial la pluviométrie
dès sa meuse plus acide on n'en parle
plus maintenant
mais voilà et les effets toxiques sur
sur les forêts donc ce réseau qui
constitue un réseau européen de
placettes forestière existe toujours
mais les phénomènes liés à la
disparition notamment
enfin la diminution très très fort des
émissions de soufre et de la
concentration du dioxyde de soufre ont
largement tempéré ce problème qui était
sans doute le premier problème de
qualité de l'air dans les années 80
merci vous êtes intéressé en 2014 ou
coût écologique non payées relatif donc
aux émissions dans l'air est-ce que vous
pouvez rapidement nous en présenter des
principales conclusions quel est selon
vous le coût de la de la dette
écologique et qu'est ce que représente
la pollution de l'air en termes de
pourcentage je dirais dans le coût de
cette dette éthique écologique par non
peut-être que mes collègues pour
pourront compléter puisque c'étaient les
études menées en partenariat avec avec
l'insee le service d'études économiques
alors pour l'instant le concept des
coûts écologiques non payées n'est pas
de nature à pouvoir peut-être répondre
typiquement à l'ensemble de la dette
écologique et quelle est la part de la
pollution de l'air on l'a lancé à titre
on va dire d'expérimentation sur des
concepts qui vise d'une certaine manière
à corriger les indicateurs de richesse
une de vos questions portaient sur le le
pib les limites du pib et on est
typiquement dans ce type de programme
est l'une des approches
qu'on a cherché à un peu à challenge et
c'était le concept d' épargne nette
ajustée
développé par la banque mondiale et l'ue
notre approche a été de mettre en place
des études sectorielles d'une part sur
les émissions dans l'air de gaz à effet
de serre on a concentré sa sueur sur le
co2 d'autre part sur quelques polluants
de dans l'air pour essayer de chiffrier
chiffré secteur par secteur
en tout quatre types d'émissions dans
les milieux ce que pouvait représenter
théoriquement cette dette écologique
puisque les coûts écologiques non payées
consiste à mesurer un agrégat comptable
parce que là c'est un exercice de
comptabilité qu'on appelle dette
écologique il le mesurais par
différentes méthodes d'évaluation
économique ça va être les mesures de
restauration milieu qui aurait été
pollués des mesures d'abattement
supplémentaires sur des émissions qu'on
peut estimer au prorata des efforts déjà
consentis par les secteurs économiques
des mesures économiques impact par
exemple d'une taxe carbone
en tout cas des années un signal prix
voilà donc on va selon le type de
mesures aboutir à des chiffrages
théorique qu'aurait dû consentir les
secteurs émetteurs pour ramener les
pollutions ou les émissions au niveau au
niveau choisi cette dette s'accumule
année après année et les résultats qu'on
a pu dire encore une fois c'est
l'exercice purement purement théorique
mais qui a pour objectif de pousser des
concepts à l'échelon international
sur le cas de la pollution de l'air on a
fait aussi l'exercice pour le pour le
co2 offrant tout cas les églises à effet
de serre en cumulant sept cette dette
sur un scénario prospectif
on atteignait 12 milliards d'euros
deux à l'horizon 2030 de dette
écologique et donc pour pour donner un
exemple on est environ dix fois celui
actuellement on peut mesurer sur les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
rapport aux objectifs fixés est aussi un
point qui est important par rapport à
ces concepts c'est que on est dans des
niveaux qui sont pas intangibles
cette dette mesurer avec les niveaux
objectifs qu'on peut avoir en 2010 2015
aurait été différente
au début des années 2000 puisque on a
relevé un certain nombre de en tout cas
on a abaissé un certain nombre de seuils
relevé un certain nombre d'exigences
on a changé aussi des systèmes de
mesures notamment ce qui concerne les
particules donc on voit bien que le coût
peut augmenter non seulement en raison
des émissions mais aussi en en raison de
l'évolution des objectifs réglementaires
et c'est aussi quelque chose qu'il faut
prendre en compte c'est que les
exigences réglementaires en fonction de
nouveautés sanitaires ou autres peuvent
être abaissée ce qui était le cas dans
les années 2000 et les périodes sont pas
forcément sont pas comparables par
contre laissé relatif de cette dette
écologique liée à l'air par rapport à
d'autres secteurs pour l'instant n'est
pas disponible
merci pardon madame archimbaud juin non
je croyais j'avais l'impression
j'avais une question en tête mais très
différente
inversement avez vous évalué
positivement les économies faites ou les
gains faits
lorsqu'une mesure positive a été prise
en matière de diminution de la pollution
de l'air c'est une question optimiste
une question qui vise à encourager des
bonnes pratiques
je ne pas être peut-être connaissez-vous
ddd des études de ce type contre je n'ai
pas stricto sensu en tête d'études qui
répondent à votre question mais ce que
je peux dire quand même c'est que dans
les analyses coûts-bénéfices que l'on
ait conduit à effectuer sur un certain
nombre de projets d'infrastructures
notamment le transport par exemple il
est bien pris en considération les
externalités
pollution d'heure entre autres
environnementale de manière générale
donc quand il y a un projet qui conduit
à réduire les pressions et les
pollutions
ça joue bien ça joue bien positivement
dans le bilan socio économique
c'est-à-dire pour la société le bilan
économique pour la société des avantages
des inconvénients
donc ça ne répond pas stricto sensu à
votre question il n'ya pas deux mais à
chaque fois qu'on étudie un projet avec
donc notamment la méthodologie
maintenant renouveler au commissariat
général à la stratégie et à prospectives
enfin france 3 et j pardon des us au
travail des dernières de des années
passées de réactualisation de tout de
tout cette méthodologie d'analysé coûts
bénéfices
donc nous nous intégrons de manière
monétariser dans l'est dans les
évaluations que bénéfices nous intégrons
les bénéfices liés à des avantages
procurés par certains projets oui
deuxième question c'est donc dans le
dans la même optique c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous voulez intégrer
vous avez les moyens de l'intégrer ou
vous envisagez de l'intégrer je ne sais
pas un feu dans les tableaux jusque dans
les tableaux financiers
alors parce que c'est c'est une question
aujourd'hui d'arriver enfin d'arriver à
ce que dans l'administration on soit
reconnue mais je ne sais pas si c'est ça
vous est possible que l'externalisation
des coûts soit soirée à terme a dit
c'est quoi
et que ça apparaisse finalement dans les
tableaux financiers ça puisse apparaître
dans les tableaux financiers d'un projet
d'aménagement ou d'un projet industriel
ou ou d'un autre projet alors la réponse
c'est non
c'est à dire qu'il ya bien un distinguo
qui est fait entre le calcul financier
qui est enfin quand il s'agit d'un
porteur de projet d'ailleurs privé il va
répondre à des considérations purement
financières de rentabilité financière
qui va devoir exposer à ses créanciers
notamment
donc on est vraiment dans une logique
purement financière ce moment là mais
donc il ya l analyse coûts-bénéfices
calcul socio-économique qui est requise
en particulier dans l'est dans les
enquêtes publiques
quand il s'agit de deux infrastructures
de transport notamment et là on fait un
calcul effectivement qui va au delà du
calcul financier pour ajouter les
avantages monétariser mais également les
coûts les coûts monétarisme c'est à dire
qu'un projet qui effectivement et autres
quand on regarde l'environnement un
projet qui augmentent les pressions
environnementales
on va traduire ça en termes de coûts
socioéconomiques parce que ce coup
l'idée c'est que au delà de du calcul
financier que l'agent privé
parfois épaulé par évidemment la
puissance publique
au delà de ceux de ce calcul on est on
oublie effectivement des coûts ou des
avantages laisser à la société et au
contribuable donc pour le futur les
générations futures donc le calcul
socio-économique qui sert effectivement
à essayer d'appréhender ce qui n'est pas
internaliser par le l'agent privé qui ne
raisonnent qu'avec un un calcul
financier alors c'est un peu caricatural
ce que je dis parce que évidemment quand
même les acteurs privés eux aussi ils
ont parfois intérêt à voir loin et à
internaliser quand même un certain
nombre d' avantages environnementaux
en particulier quand on pense au gaz à
effet de serre aujourd'hui les grands
pollueurs évidemment se projette à très
long terme et évaluer les conséquences
de leur investissement aujourd'hui en
matière de 2 des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre sachez comprenant
parfaitement que demain ils ont la
rentabilité financière de leur projet
sera peut-être affectés en fonction des
évolutions de cadre réglementaire qui
font très attention à ça mais
aujourd'hui stricto sensu il ya bien une
différence faite entre le calcul
financier et le calcul socio économique
ces deux choses con con mais conjugue sa
pause mais qui ne ce quine ce qui ne se
mêlent pas totalement
voilà le référentiel transport pour
finir le qui est sorti l'année dernière
le nouveau référentiel transport qui qui
qui a été construit à partir des travaux
à frans stratégie donne toute cette
méthodologie pour le calcul socio
économique
donc il est accessible sur le fond je
pourrais vous donner les références
évidemment la merci pardon madame la
rapporteure j'aurais de deux questions
vous posez en rapport notamment votre
étude que vous et publiée en octobre
2013 dans lequel vous estimez un coût
pour la pollution de l'air pour la
société entre 20 et 30 milliards
est-ce que dedans vous intégrez le coup
des effets cocktail de des différents
polluants ce que c'est c'est qu'à lui et
ça fait partie de votre calcul c'est ma
première question
la deuxième question est en lien avec le
secteur des transports est ce que vous
avez des éléments sur la fiabilité du
contrôle de
du respect des normes euro est ce que
vous pensez que dans ce
dans ce dispositif il devra
éventuellement des conflits d'intérêts
jeu finira par une question très rapide
est ce que vous pensez que la lutte
contre la pollution de l'air est
suffisamment bien appréhender pour pour
le grand public est ce qu'on en fait une
communication assez assez facile pour
diffuser auprès de notre grand public la
question de la police en l'air je vous
remercie
je vais commencer puis donnera la parole
à doris miklos qui a fait l'étude sur le
les coûts pour la société de la
population l'ère de la pollution d'air
donc la base
enfin pour schématiser la méthodologie
de l'étude c'est l'utilisation de thé
d'une évaluation des impacts sanitaires
première premier bloc et deuxième bloc
c'est là la transposition de cette
évaluation des impacts sanitaires en
matière en calcul monétaire avec des
valeurs de référence compte dans notre
jargon on parle de valeur tutélaire donc
votre question sur les cocktails
c'est largement une question sur le
premier bloc sur l'impact sanitaire
donc c'est pas notre compétence notre
nounou nous utilisons évidemment pour
l'évaluation des impacts sanitaires tout
un tas d'études qui sont faites qui sont
faites par d'autres mais je vais quand
même passé la parole parce que moi même
je suis peut-être à la limite de mes
loris tu peut compléter éventuellement
si jamais à ma connaissance il ya plutôt
pas de dinde effet cocktail dans ce
qu'on avait pris en compte
alors effectivement ça relève bien du
domaine effectivement plus de
l'épidémiologiste
ce qui n'est pas notre vocation aussi
jdd
néanmoins ce matin effectivement on a eu
à un brillant exposé de deux langues
c'est ce qui présentait à fait comme et
moi j'ai été très étonné par la grande
attention qu'il portait lorsqu'il
présentait polluants par polluants les
effets qu'ils prenaient bien en compte
et c est ça montre bien que derrière une
fonction exposition risque on ne mesure
pas généralement les faits que d'un seul
polluant
typiquement les particules et là aussi
c'est plutôt là aussi une question et
les serait éventuellement compléter la
mairie morar le sos sur ce sujet quand
on évalue l'impact des particules et
qu'on cherche à trouver cette fonction
exposition risque
la particule c'est plein de choses voilà
parce que là dessus se fixe par des
procédés physiques o'shea
physico-chimiques également parfois des
métaux lourds
donc on voit bien que quelque part cbc
voilà c
on ne prend on prend en compte pas
seulement l'effet de ce seul polluant
qui est la particule qui en elles-mêmes
agrège un certain nombre d'autres
produits d'autres substances chimiques
oui la cia je sais que j'ai pas les
références là mais il ya dérobé
littérature assez complète sur les
effets combinés des particules notamment
avec des particules très fines et on
voit bien que on s'est focalisé pendant
assez longtemps sur des particules de
type 10 microgrammes 10 microns
maintenant on est sûr plutôt sur les 2,5
et puis demain ça sera le niveau en
dessous qui sont qui sont effectivement
fixatrice de micropolluants sur la
question de l'information
peut-être effectivement la l'intervenant
précédent à distinguer les aspects
concentration des aspects émission en
france on a un système de toute façon
qui est héritée du règles de la
réglementation communautaire
d'informations très efficace avec
maintenant des associations agréées pour
la surveillance de la qualité de l'air
qui ont des sites accessibles et avec
des bulletins quotidiens
l'air est le seul milieu environnemental
dont on peut connaître la qualité en
quasiment en temps réel et
on combine des observations avec de la
modélisation qui permet de combler les
zones il n'y a pas de station est donc
en fonction des caractéristiques de ces
zones ont fait tourner les modèles qui
permettent d'avoir des cartes donc
régulièrement on a des cartes
d'exposition qui qu'ils sont
qui sont proposées au public 1 il ya
ainsi à pas non il ya des il ya des
sites il ya le site prévenant qu' à
hyères qui permet effectivement d'avoir
des simulations de la pollution de l'air
il ya des bulletins quotidiens
par contre bien évidemment là on est sur
la concentration en ce qui concerne les
émissions secteur par secteur
là dessus on est sur les bilans annuels
qui sont qui sont diffusées qui sont
accessibles
voilà donc c'est notamment le bilan
annuel de qualité de l'air c'est le le
rapport sur l'état de l'environnement en
france que j'ai sous le coude et qu'on
vous laissera voilà donc là il ya une
information sachant que ses
responsabilités sectorielles peuvent
varier d'une région à une autre ne sont
pas liés que au territoire français
peuvent aussi varier d'une année à une
autre
si vous me permettez je vais revenir sur
le sujet de l'effet cocktail non pas que
ce soit une obsession mais comme en fait
l'idée du rapport justement c'est
d'avoir une analyse la plus
la plus juste et la plus proche de la
réalité pour résumer ce que vous faites
ce que j'ai compris de votre exposé sur
l'impact sur l'étude et de l'impact
sanitaire
vous vous êtes donc baser sur des études
épidémiologiques et pour citer par
exemple le docteur années' maïsano
justement tout à l'heure je vais poser
la question sur le pardon l'analyse de
l'effet cocktail sait quelque chose
nous nous at elle dit qui était
compliquée à appréhender de ce que j'ai
compris des différentes analyses en fait
sur l'examen des polluants et de leurs
effets on examine les polluants les uns
à côté des autres mais pas sur leurs
effets dans leur globalité
je fais du juste sûr qu'on soit d'accord
quand vous vous analysez des 20 et 30
milliards vous vous basez sur donc ses
études épidémiologiques épidémiologique
pardon qui elle-même n'intègre pas les
effets cocktails ma question elle est
assez précise donc je voudrais des
réponses eu assez précis et s'il vous
plaît oui c'est bien cela on se base sur
des résultats dirais même d'études
d'impacts sanitaires qui ont été
réalisés voilà d'accord merci pour
revenir à une question peut-être plus
générale puisque vous concentrer un
certain nombre d'études dirait dans vos
dans ce ministère dans votre
direction est-ce que vous pouvez
peut-être en quelques mots nous nous
dire selon vous quelle est l'évolution
de la femme à partir de l'état des lieux
aujourd'hui mais un petit peu
l'évolution sur les dix dernières années
avec un petit regard prospectif que vous
sentez pas qu'intuitivement puisque si
on regarde par les différents niveaux de
pollution fin sources de pollution entre
tout ce qui est des déplacements tout ce
qui est habitat résidentiel ou bâtiments
et puis euh je dirais les pratiques
activités agricoles on voit bien selon
les évolutions tendancielles à la fois
les niveaux de pollution la
concentration
le contenu de ces pollutions qui évolue
et puis puisque vous l'avez dit je crois
que c'est vous qui l'avez dit tout à
l'heure je me souviens que c'était il ya
une petite vingtaine d'années les pluies
acides sont arrivés presque du jour au
lendemain comme un phénomène à l'époque
perçu comme nouveau il en a très vite on
est très vite arrivée elle le à
circonscrire cette ce problème donc et
magma ma question c'est comment vous
percevez ces grandes évolutions
est ce qu'on a aujourd'hui les bons
outils et est ce que vous pensez dans le
cadre de notre mission que le fait
d'évaluer les coûts économiques et
financiers peuvent compléter les
observations qui sont parus ressorti au
travers de vos études
justement pour nous remettre nous amener
plus facilement sur l'objectif qui est
de réduire significativement et
progressivement la pollution de l'air en
france notamment mais on a bien compris
que c'était pas qu'on n'était pas une
île
je vais commencer à répondre je passerai
la parole aleri morin en fait il ya deux
questions d'autres questions dont cas le
bilan
ils ont sur dix ans donc là on est on
est plutôt dans une tendance à la baisse
en moyenne et c'est tout le c'est tout
le problème en fait que la pollution de
l'air comme d'autres pressions
environnementales c'est qui c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que des chiffres
en moyenne
donc il faut regarder effectivement faut
être très attentif à des aspects
spatiaux et alors vous parlez de l'air
intérieur jeu dans la cession à la fin
de la session précédente
voilà c'est le même type dessus il ya
des spécificités dans chacun des sujets
qu'il faut regarder et
ce garde est effectivement de tirer
totalement 2
enfin une d une conclusion définitive à
partir de chiffres moyens tout de même
il faut faire très attention et on pense
particulièrement à ces aspects spatiaux
quand on pense à des activités ou à des
fins d à ce qui se passe près des
infrastructures de transport des routes
ce qui se passe aussi dans l'est en
milieu rural c'est d'autres types de
pressions qui peuvent être très
localisés je vais passer la parole à
l'airé morard pour compléter sur cet
aspect là mais il y avait une deuxième
question sur laquelle je peux je peux
quand même donné quelques éléments aussi
nous croyons enfin comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire au sujet de la
question précédente que l'outil de
monétarisation de ces externalités de
c2c pollution est un outil très
important pour le décideur public
c'est un éclairage qui dépassent
effectivement la simple simple constat
des évolutions de telle ou telle
pression environnementale pour en faire
une synthèse
et l'outil de commencer sur habilité
c'est l'outil de la monnaie ça ne veut
pas dire que ces forces et ça ne veut
pas dire que c'est de l'argent qui a
derrière nécessairement c'est un outil
qui permet de mettre en regard
différentes pressions différents
différents différents sujets ce qui ce
qui permet d'arbitrer de données en tout
cas des éléments d'arbitrage pour le
décideur public donc nous nous sommes
des utilisateurs du calcul coûts
bénéfices
nous faisons un certain nombre d'études
qui sont publiques sur un certain nombre
de sujets qui peuvent
qu'ils ne soient pas nécessairement
uniquement sur la pollution de l'air ça
peut être ça peut être la pollution de
l'eau gelée déjà dit on a fait des
études sur la pollution l'eau avec cette
méthodologie et nous pensons vraiment
que c'est dans ce sens qu'il faut
améliorer les choses pour enrichir
finalement les débats publics et donner
aux décideurs publics les mois les
moyens de faire des choix en tout en
toute connaissance de cause alors je
passe la parole à 1 valérie morard pour
compléter sur les aspects peut-être
bilan
sur dix ans oui peut-être même je pense
qu'il faudrait prendre une d'intérieur
était plus longue
je crois qu'ils on a toujours encore une
fois les normes ont évolué enfin il faut
toujours rappeler quand même que la
pollution de l'air était bien plus forte
il ya quelques décennies
ça on a tendance effectivement oublié
que l'air que nous respirons même si
nous vivons avec des nouvelles aux
émissions c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose il y avait plus de particules
notamment le choix du mix énergétique a
à jouer
certainement donc voilà donc c'était
juste pour se dire en dehors de cette
période de 10 ans bonfoh faut toujours
se dire que nos générations précédentes
n'étaient pas forcément mieux lotis en
matière ce n'était pas les mêmes
s'étaient pas les mêmes menaces c'est
tout si on regarde sur les suivis dont
on peut avoir une traçabilité une
comparabilité
il ya une amélioration globale comme
l'indiqué xavier bonnet donc la
pollution la console les concentrations
de polluants dans l'air diminue
globalement mais avec des différences
bien évidemment selon les polluants qui
ont dû vous être rappelé par les autres
intervenants
j'ai parlé du dioxyde de soufre ou là
bon il ya eu sous l'effet de plusieurs
impacts le carburant les efforts des
industries la désindustrialisation aussi
du tissu économique français enfin
toutes ces causes là ont contribué à
faire baisser non seulement le
concentration mais aussi les émissions
il ya des résultats très positifs sur le
monoxyde de carbone par contre sur
d'autres polluants ont peine à
finalement amélioré améliorer les choses
bon il récentes alertes
parisienne sont là pour en témoigner on
a toujours sur certains types de
particules des problèmes on a des
problèmes sur l'ozone et ceci sous deux
angles
lorsqu'on parle de non-respect de
réglementation c'est à la fois des
dépassements ponctuels de seuil
mais ça peut être aussi une
concentration moyenne annuelle qui est
pas forcément très bonne alors là dessus
ça c'est un des points qui a été évalué
dans dans les études sur les coûts pour
la santé
on s'aperçoit que effectivement une
pollution chronique même inférieur au
seuil réglementaire a sans doute plus
d'effet sur sur la santé que des
dépassements ponctuels de seuil qui
concentrent souvent l'attention parce
qu'ils sont ils sont les faits de la
réglementation donc d une amélioration
de ta pour certains polluants et des
difficultés pour d'autres je veux pas
évoquer plus enfin sauf si vous le
souhaitez avec des questions émergentes
qui ne sont pas actuellement
suffisamment traité qui font l'objet
d'initiatives régionales d'associations
de surveillance de qualité de l'air
c'est notamment le cas des pesticides ou
là il ya des mesures
on sait qu'il ya une exposition par
contre mon camp d' éléments
épidémiologiques d'autant plus que
chaque pesticide à des comportements
particuliers puisque on a différentes
familles autant quasiment que de
polluants dans l'air actuellement
mesurées sinon beaucoup plus
on sait qui a une exposition qui n'est
pas négligeable compte tenu de l'air
ventilé chaque jour par un être humain
l'exposition est sans doute plus forte
que celle qu'il a au travers de l'eau du
robinet quand bien même celle-ci serait
aux limites de potabilité
ceci étant dit qu'on n'est pas les
effets physiologiques pour l'instant y'a
pas de norme donc là dessus il ya des
initiatives visant à essayer de
commencer à préparer
l'inclusion dans la réglementation de la
mesure de ces pesticides mais voilà donc
ça c'est un problème qui n'est pas
nouveau puisqu'il existait auparavant
mais qui est nouveau parce qu'on le
mesure bien maintenant et même si la
mesure est sur l'ensemble dû territoire
métropolitain
merci notre collègue madame archimbaud
oui moi je voulais vous vous demandez un
peu votre votre opinion sur la question
suivante alors vous avez évoqué un
certain nombre de secteurs que vous
suivez particulièrement sur le secteur
sensible il se posa à nous enfin quand
on a des arbitrages à faire la question
aussi de lait d'une évaluation technique
d'une évaluation qui demande des
compétences de techniciens d'ingénieurs
jeu je pense à un problème précis qui
est en débat qui était en débat ici dans
plusieurs commissions et qui est
toujours en débat dans dans dans ce pays
ça prend un exemple très précis 1 mais
c'est pour vous expliquer ce que parce
que je voudrais ce que je recherche
et j'ai pensé à ça quand je vous ai
entendu madame évoqué les effets
combinés des particules fines avec
d'autres polluants enfin lesquels
particules fines pourrait fixer d'autres
produits sains
c'est comment évaluer ce qui sort des
filtres à particules les nouveaux
filtres à particules
c'est une question très sensible
aujourd'hui je je la pose parce qu'elle
est très sensible et que l'on se trouve
devant devant des avis vraiment
contradictoire qui ne peuvent être
tranchées
selon moi que
par des équipes techniques qui seraient
mobilisés par les pouvoirs publics enfin
qu'ils travailleraient qui serait qu'il
ne serait pas sous la pression des uns
des autres quoi est ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui en france et je suppose
qu'on en a mais comment les mobiliser
peut-être l'immobiliser vous des
ingénieurs des techniciens enfin ou des
cabinets ou des équipes de recherche qui
pourrait répondre aussi à ces questions
là oui alors effectivement que ça me
fait penser que j'ai pas répondu à la
question sur le contrôle des normes euro
et en fait ça c'est quand même une
question qui n'est pas du tout dans
notre compétence comme ça général c'est
pour violer les normes rohs elles ont
été travaillés plus tôt par la direction
générale de l'énergie et du climat
si vous êtes si vous avez prévu de les
auditionner aussi voilà donc ils vous
ont je pense qu'ils vous vous rend il
vous diront tout ce qu'ils font sur ce
sujet là
non effectivement nous part du principe
que la norme était dictée est effective
donc après
oui tout un tas de d'institutions
publiques qui contribue à faire en sorte
que les contrôles soient effectivement
effectif je ne peux pas m'avancer plus
là merci on va on va terminer par une
question dite de procédure par madame la
porte
merci monsieur le président juste une
pour ma complète information et à
l'information de la commission je
voudrais savoir comment vous validez les
rapports quel est le processus
décisionnel
quand vous décidez de faire le dernier
rapport que vous avez publié en 2013
notamment sur le coût économique
quelle est la chaîne de décisions
comment vous vous organisez comment le
rapport et il validé pour ensuite faire
l'objet d'une publication
je remercie alors quand il s'agit de
quatre pages comme ça c'est une
publication dont je suis le directeur de
publication c'est moi une fille est qui
qui valident donc bien évidemment
donc il s'agissait par exemple du
travail de doris nicklausse qui est un
qui a été relu en interne par un certain
nombre de personnes dont intermédiaire
le sous-directeur entre le chef de
bureau et et moi même donc c'est c'est
donc nous sommes nous sommes déjà 2
alors de formation d'ingénieur et
d'économistes donc nous avons sa
compétence de diriger ce type de deux
publications
et puis comme ces publications sont
quand même présenté avant d'être publiés
dans différents cénacle en particulier
la commission des comptes de l'économie
et de l'environnement c'est bien ça le
titre de l'économie et de
l'environnement
ça a été le cas pour le pur c'est pour
ses publications donc il ya eu tout un
travail en groupe de travail amont de
cette commission de relecture
voilà deux donc de mise en contradiction
si vous voulez ce qui permet de faire
avancer l'étude la de la rendre plus
robuste
voilà c'est comme ça qu'on travaille
alors nous ne sommes pas pour autant une
revue scientifique
c'est ça la question nous n'allons pas
de comité de scientifiques de relecture
voilà c'est ça le sait comme toutes les
publications
oui alors je vais passer la parole à
vers les rimes rare qui va qui va nous
parler d'une exception est une exception
c'est se documentant kiki qu'il synthèse
qu'adriana qui est notre obligation
internationale au titre de la convention
de la rue sur l'environnement france là
ce rapport est présenté et corrigé
validée par un conseil scientifique avec
les différentes composantes thématique
du ministère de l'écologie transport
logement environnement développement
durable qui sont représentés dans ce
conseil scientifique donc là une
validation conseil scientifique puis
comme c'est un ouvrage collectif
l'inserm lane c'est ce lien et c'est
aussi contribuer et bien il me reste à
vous remercier en plus nous sommes à
l'heure nous avons commencé avec cinq
minutes de retard nous sommes à l'heure
il me reste à vous remercier toutes et
tous à vous souhaiter un bon appétit
et puis comme on n'est pas très loin
quand même un bon ton de pâques puisque
on a un jour de plus
merci à vous de votre écoute et bien
entendu je vous lasser comme je disais
un certain nombre de documents et nous
restons évidemment à votre disposition
pour tout complément
merci beaucoup d'autres voilà pour ces
auditions sur le thème de la pollution
de l'air elle était menée par la
commission denquête ici au sénat qui
s'interrogent sur l'impact économique et
financier de la pollution de l'air des
auditions vous pouvez voir et revoir en
replay en vod sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
des auditions qui interviennent dans un
contexte de pics de pollution dans de
nombreuses villes européennes et
notamment paris voilà tout de suite vous
avez rendez vous avec delphine girard
pour votre journal le 24 heures sénat
très bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires